we're going to begin with the growing
fears that the war in ukraine could
cause a disaster at europe's largest
nuclear plant the u.n secretary general
is calling for a demilitarized zone
around the facility which is in russian
occupied territory in ukraine so this is
tricky both sides blame each other for
shelling the area this morning russia
said its forces are there to prevent
what it called a chernobyl scenario
that's a reference of course to europe's
worst nuclear accident charlie daggett
is in ukraine tracking this growing
crisis charlie this sure sounds very
dicey good morning to you
it is it is serious gail good morning to
you we are at the hostimal airfield just
north of kyiv this is the scene of one
of the early victories for ukrainian
forces but today another fight is
underway where the battle over the
nuclear power plant has been pushed to
the brink
both sides issue ominous warnings of an
attack today ukrainian officials say
russia plans to stage a false flag
incident at europe's largest nuclear
power plant and blame ukraine just hours
after russia accused ukraine of trying
to stage an accident there the threats
are timed to coincide with a visit to
the country by turkish president tayyip
erdogan and u.n chief antonio guterres
the area needs to be demilitarized
and we must tell it
as it is
any potential damage to zaporizia is
suicide
president zielinski demanding an
immediate and unconditional withdrawal
russia must stop all provocations and
certainly all shelling he said we cannot
allow russia to deliberately put us all
on the edge of a radiation catastrophe
ukraine accuses russia of using it as a
military base for troops and equipment
shaky social media video appears to show
russian military vehicles parked inside
the complex
russian forces captured the plant in the
early days of the war but in the past
two weeks it's come under sustained
shelling as fighting intensifies in the
southeast
while there has been no let up in
russia's relentless missile strikes on
eastern cities like kharkiv where
officials say at least 19 have died and
dozens more have been wounded in two
days of heavy bombardment
the russian government has already
rejected a u.n proposal to demilitarize
the plant calling it unacceptable saying
a withdrawal would make it even more
vulnerable
vlad
charlie dagetta in ukraine for us
charlie thank you